- I ranked "The Good Doctor"
as the second most accurate medical drama
of all time.
And then ABC gave me
an exclusive first look
at the Season 5 premiere,
which premieres Monday,
September 27th, 10/9 Central on ABC.
Let's see what Dr. Shaun
Murphy's up to the season,
and huge thank you to ABC
for sponsoring this video.
Pew!
- Shaun Robert.
- Aw, look at them getting married.
Everyone's suited up.
Oh, storm incoming.
(thunder rumbles)
(classical music)
(thunder claps)
Remember those who are diagnosed
with autism spectrum
disorder are susceptible
to really loud sounds.
They hear them louder.
The processing of auditory
stimuli is different.
It can be very uncomfortable,
so much so that they
can have a panic attack
just because of a loud sound
or other external stimuli.
(classical music)
Definitely the first
gentlemen to wear earplugs
in the middle of his wedding.
(thunder claps)
(guests screaming)
What's wedding, like, norms?
Is there bad luck if it's thundering
and pouring during your wedding?
Or is that like good luck,
like a pigeon pooping on you?
(thunder claps)
(screams intensify)
Oh no!
- Hi.
- I had a great time last night.
- Me too. Wanna go grab some breakfast?
- I gotta get to the hospital.
- Oh, don't do that doctor thing,
"I gotta get to the hospital."
If you're having a person spend the night,
eat breakfast, enjoy each
other's company, plan for it.
- Perhaps, I should let you go.
- No, no.
I was hoping for a little
excitement this morning.
- Mm, spicy.
(knocking on door)
- Just give me two minutes
to make this go away. Yeah?
- Ooh. So much romance, and
the episode just started.
- Some shortness of breath,
occasional blurred vision
and headaches, and this
morning, my urine was foamy.
- Is she pregnant?
'Cause that could be a problem.
- Any blood in your urine?
- A little.
- You take 20 milligrams
of Ritalin LA a day?
- For my ADHD.
- Blurred vision and headaches
can be side effects from Ritalin.
Would you be willing
to stop your medication
for a couple of days?
See if they're causing
any of your symptoms?
- I'll refer any complaints
about my behavior to you.
- What's interesting to me
is she's having a wide range
of symptoms outside of
blurry vision and headaches,
that warrants further investigation.
Whenever you're trying to decide
whether or not it's due to
a medication side effect,
you're trying to rule
out any organic causes,
then you could try doing
things with medications,
but jumping to medications
right off the bat,
unless it's like a really
well-known side effect
and it's only that one symptom,
doesn't usually happen.
- We're gonna run some labs
into a CT of your kidneys.
- Let's say the foamy urine
could be a sign of kidney stones.
The first test you would do
there wouldn't be a CT scan,
unless the patient was having
other symptoms like back pain.
So I would do like a urine dipstick test,
make sure that we have the
presence of blood there,
then send it out for a urine microscopy,
see if there's crystals there.
And then what you can do,
is you do a 24 hour urine collection
to see the total amount
of the calcium oxalate
or uric acid or whatnot in the urine.
- Renal pelvis looks clean.
- You sound disappointed.
- But what's that?
On the right kidney.
Could be a mass.
She needs a kidney biopsy.
- Interesting for conditions like this,
we usually page the
interventional radiologist,
as well as the oncologist to decide
if we see suspicious features on the scan.
There's also conditions like
Polycystic Kidney Disease,
which just develop a lot
of cysts in your kidneys,
potentially leading to
needing a kidney transplant
or even having it become a fatal disease.
- Have you always had fat ankles?
- Rude.
- Only if the answer is yes,
if the answer is no, it's a symptom.
- Edema in the lower extremities
for a young person could
be a sign of proteinuria,
which means she's going
into kidney failure.
She could have a nephrotic syndrome.
She has blood in her urine
so she could have like FSG
caused by HIV.
There's a lot of possibilities here.
- Are you overwhelmed
planning the wedding?
Because Park and Lim thought
you might be overwhelmed.
- Nope, not at all.
I've got it. It's gonna be great.
- Great.
- There should be a term called whelm.
What if there's not too
much, but there's a lot.
Whelmed.
- Nice exposure of the right tonsil.
Visibility can be tough with kids.
- That's true. When you're
doing any kind of procedure
in their oral pharyngeal space,
it's sometimes hard to get a visual.
- There's a firm, irregular
mass in this tonsil.
- Tonsil stone?
- Get that to pathology.
- I didn't quite see it.
It looked like a tonsil stone.
I hope it's not a tumor of any sort.
- Riley's throat, it's
still really bothering him.
- We had to remove additional tissue
because your son's tonsils
showed signs of cancerous cells.
- Riley has cancer?
- The cancer on your son's
tonsil is cervical cancer.
- Interesting.
Cervical cancer in the
sense of HPV induced cancer.
- He got it from you.
He was exposed to your cancerous
cells in the birth canal,
which he likely inhaled.
Jackson may also have
been exposed during birth.
We need to scan both you-
- We definitely need to find
out her pap smear results
because that is how we
screen for cervical cancer.
The human papilloma virus HPV
has certain high-risk subtypes
that predispose you to
the development of cancer.
That's why we recommend
patients to get vaccinated
against HPV in order to prevent the virus
thereby preventing the cancer.
It's actually one of the
only vaccines that we have
that prevents cancer.
- The PET scan shows
increased metabolic activity
in the mother's uterus
and the son's trachea.
- Oh no.
- They both have cancer.
- Yeah. That's the terrible part
about human papilloma virus,
they can cause cancer there
in the anal genital region,
oral cavity in the oral mucosa
as seen with this child.
And then it could spread,
if it is advanced.
- Your cancer is quite advanced.
Most cervical cancers are detected early
with regular pap smears.
- This is a really important point.
Not only should you be
getting regular visits
with your doctor for a
whole host of reasons,
but you should be making
sure that your pap smears
are up to date from the age of 21.
It means that from the age of 21,
you start getting them every three years.
Once you hit the age of 30,
the guidelines now change
and say that we should do pap
smears, plus HPV cotesting,
which means we also check
for HPV at the same time.
And if both are negative at that time,
you can spread out to every five years.
(intense dramatic music)
- Endoscopic mucosal tracheal resection.
If Jackson's tumor was seeded
via exposure during birth,
which is a very reasonable assumption,
then we can reasonably
assume that it is localized.
Endoscopic resection
should allow for a recovery
of days instead of weeks.
- Talk to the mother.
- Talk to the surgical team.
Why didn't they figure that out?
Shaun is a super surgeon.
(machines beeping)
- [Surgeon] You're at the mass.
- [Shaun] It has a wide base.
No easy way to loop my snare around it.
- Oh no. Is it?
- [Surgeon] Is it pulsating?
- Oh no.
- Is it a blood vessel?
Is it around, is it
surrounding a blood vessel?
- [Surgeon] It has a major
arterial feeder from his aorta.
We can't remove it from this angle
without risking a massive bleed.
- The interesting part
about tumors is that they go
through a process called angiogenesis,
which is the formation
of new blood vessels.
They do this in order
to keep themselves alive
and to feed themselves to grow.
And in those cases, you have
to perform an open surgery
where you actually go in
and separate the blood vessel carefully,
while making sure that you're
having adequate blood supply
throughout the rest of the body.
- Abort the surgery.
(intense dramatic music)
- I think I know what they're gonna do.
And I'm not a surgeon.
I'm gonna try and predict it.
I think that they're gonna do
a radical coil embolization
where they're gonna go
in through either a vein
or the femoral vein, put in a catheter
and they're gonna embolize it
like as if it's an aneurysm.
(playful music)
Dude, are you serious?
- [Man] Hey, hey.
- I would like to make a toast.
I have never ever seen you as happy
as you are right now with Lea.
- He does look happier.
Like, when I think about the first episode
of "The Good Doctor" that
I watched on this channel,
he looks much happier here.
- There's been some ups and downs,
little bit like a roller coaster.
- Okay.
- You guys have managed it so well.
A whole lot better than I have.
(guests laughing)
Is that funny?
But here's to many, many, many
years of
happiness.
At least two, maybe three.
(dramatic music)
- What?! That is not where
you make a relevation,
revelation of that caliber!
What are you doing?
That was viscerally painful to watch.
- Dr. Lim.
- Excuse me, who are you?
And what are you doing
in my operating room?
- I'm Salen Morrison.
- What are you doing there?
You're not surgically
prepared to be there.
That's dangerous for all parties involved.
- Please page Dr. Andrews and
have him come get his patient.
- Or security.
(machines beeping)
- Oh, I feel...
Something's wrong.
- Stat.
- What causes kidney
lesions, shortness of breath,
swollen ankles and heart irregularities?
- Ahhh.
Amyloid deposits.
A tumor that secretes
some sort of hormone.
- Every time we get close to
doing the biopsy on this woman,
something dark blocks us.
- Unless.
Look at her blood work.
She said she'd stop her meds,
but her Ritalin level today is
over double when she came in.
That could cause her heart irregularities.
- That could.
- She is...
(suspense music)
- What?! This is like out of this world.
It doesn't happen, but it could happen.
Click here to check out a full playlist
of all my "Good Doctor" reactions.
And don't forget to check
out the season premiere
of "The Good Doctor", September
27th, 10/9 Central on ABC.
Huge thanks to ABC for
sponsoring this video
and as always stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)